[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: Hi, I'm in
the dev zone once again,
but now I'm with
Terrence Ryan, who's
one of my favorite co-workers.
I'm not going to lie about that.
But so this demo in particular,
it's a digital postcard.
Is that right?
TERRY RYAN: Yeah,
that's kind of the idea.
The idea is you take
a selfie or picture.
And we will bounce it
around our network,
our private network
all around the world,
and print it out for you.
So the pictures that
you get over here
are pictures that have traveled
around the world digitally.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh my gosh.
And so that's what these
stamps are, each data center.
TERRY RYAN: Each data center,
we have a stamp for it.
And it doesn't stamp it
until it's in that data set.
JOANNA SMITH: Now when you
talk about a private network,
you mean the actual physical
cables and data centers
that Google built
around the world, right?
TERRY RYAN: Yeah, exactly,
the same data centers
and same infrastructure
that powers search and mail.
Also under the covers, it's
available to Google Cloud
customers as their
private network.
So whenever you talk between
one machine and another machine
on Google Cloud, it's always
traveling on our network.
It never leaves the network.
And so you get much
better performance
in terms of being
able to communicate
and security because
it's not leaving-- it's
not on the public internet.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, my gosh.
This is actually one
of my favorite facts
about Google Cloud.
It's a fun fact, which is
we built an infrastructure
to power our search.
And then we started opening
that up to other people
so that you don't have
to reinvent the wheel.
But it's really important
that we make it easy to use.
Was this pretty easy to set up?
TERRY RYAN: Absolutely.
One of the great things
about Google Cloud,
the default networking
in our projects,
is if all the machines are in
the same project, all the VMs--
the VMs are what are powering
the relaying and the stamping
here--
if they're all in
the same project,
then they are automatically
wired to talk to one another
without the developer
having to do any work
to make that happen.
And so what that
allows you to do
is kind of get
started without having
to set up VPNs and VPCs
to get all that working.
All of that is done for you.
All the routing is done for you.
And if you want, this is
an open source project.
So you can actually pull down,
and see how we set it up,
and see that it really
is that super simple.
JOANNA SMITH: And I like that it
makes it accessible to someone
who might not have
that networking
experience or
background, but so long
as they can
understand the theory,
they can actually get going.
TERRY RYAN: Yep, exactly.
JOANNA SMITH: This
is so exciting.
I love this demo.
I am so happy to
take home my photos.
And more importantly, the
fact that it is open source
means that anyone at
home can play along,
even if you don't get to have
your own cute photo to take
home.
And I hope y'all
have a great time.
Thanks for joining
me in the Dev Zone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]